don't be afraid take risk let the Rope
go let the net go we can do whatever we
believe we can do and we don't need
anybody's permission to do it but ours
so I don't need you focusing on cars and
money and stuff you're gonna get dad's I
need you to focus on why you were born
in the first place the motivation
watching top 10 with believe nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who went from
dropping out of high school and being
homeless on the streets to becoming one
of the biggest motivational speakers on
the planet and impacting the lives of
millions of people he's Eric Thomas and
here's my take on his top ten rules a
success vol 8 also if you want to know
what Eric Thomas and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence program where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence to link the join is in
description below get that gold get that
dream and I'm just been telling you
drive it and drive it and drive it and
drive it what I've been talking about is
consistency I have boundaries
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one surround yourself with greatness
if something happens no matter who you
are if you're average or if you're good
when you get around greatness and you
stay around greatness you start
listening the great podcast and reading
great books and you start hanging around
great people and you start becoming a
part of great masterminds guys you just
evolved and I don't know what happened
but every year I went from a high school
dropout and homeless so I started to be
coming every single day more of who I am
and I can't believe it my next goal is
to win the Nobel Prize why I had to come
up with something listen to me you have
to be careful when you hang around
average people all they're going to do
is tell you what they can't do and
that's okay that they can't do it but
that has absolutely nothing to do with
us we can go from being homeless and
high school dropouts to having PhDs
writing books and becoming the voice of
a generation we can do whatever we
believe we can do and we don't need
anybody's permission to do it but ours
rule number two applying what you learn
you know you got to be careful with like
this motivation and the books you read
yeah but you got to be careful that
you're not doing it like for
entertainment you filming I think a lot
of you do it for entertainment so it's
like I'm watching Serina play that's
purely other than the fact that I'm
gonna take some of the content and use
it you know to speak that's purely
entertainment
I'm just watching her do what she do
that's pure entertainment and so for
some of you when you when you listen to
motivation you're not using it to fuel
you you feel me like you need to use it
to fuel you so let's just say you can do
real estate are you scared like you
should you should be listening to
specific stuff that's gonna tell you
don't be afraid take risk let the Rope
go let the net go like that's what you
should be listening to not risk random
stuff you know I'm saying like we put
stuff out but we're putting it out
because that's what we do we just put
stuff out but you got to get a catalog
and say alright I'm fearful or I don't
got that dog and if you doing business
you gotta have that dog so you just
gotta listen to a whole bunch of stuff I
see people walk around
t-shirts you look yourself in the mirror
I got that dog like whatever it is you
need then when you give books I'm tired
of people like Ellison it's like a like
a keeping up with the Jones is not like
you know what book you read for what
wait it's like you telling me what book
you read for what like just so you can
sound deep you're not doing them with
the information you feel me like you
just trying to be like in conversation
like drinking coffee and say oh yeah I
read with grit
I read grit grit was phenomenal but you
don't got no more grit I'm just saying
you don't have no more grease than you
started when you first read the book so
it's like instead of reading a book and
trying to be deep like what is the book
saying like how do you acquire grit if
you don't got none do me a favor stop
reading to be deep right some of you are
watching power you don't got no more
power after watching power are you gonna
watch it from watch what episode like
that that ain't necessarily my thing but
I'm saying if you're gonna watch it from
what I'm hearing it's some ystem cats on
there who straight-up gangsters so if
you're gonna watch it be gangsters like
for real don't watch it and don't be
gangster if you're gonna watch it and
you gonna put that stuff in your spirit
if you're gonna watch The Godfather
people I watch The Godfather for what
what did you watch The Godfather for
what did you learn when you was watching
it you watch Scarface what'd you learn I
learned some stuff from Scarface flat
out flat out I learned some stuff right
and my wife getting me all the time you
don't I'm like yo I've seen the movie I
grew up in the hood flat out and system
something I'm conscious I'm aware of so
I'm so ain't no don't go getting knocked
down on me and I ain't gonna get shot up
you understand what I'm telling you like
I'm aware of always of what's happening
you feel me so don't be why I watch
Scarface I went to the movie and saw it
I still remember the movie to this day I
still remember when my with the women
thing how the woman theme messed the
whole
messed a whole little swag up the whole
I remember his New Jack city
and stuff happening where the power
wasn't equal and that I buy I watch the
movie so you're watching it but you
ain't paying attention to it and I'm
paying attention so stop watching that's
up and not doing them with it
rule number three find your dream we go
to school for
all these years and they never really
show us the importance of dreaming right
I look at school and I'm like yo the way
school is design is this designing you
to be prepared to work for somebody else
and I'm not even upset with that but
there's little of you that you get right
y'all got to work with me because this
is deep right so I said to my son
I said to my son son I gotta ask you a
question like and I'm being serious I
said do you believe you created yourself
he was like what I like do you believe
created yourself he said no I said do
you believe there's a creator he said of
course I do I said I don't do that don't
don't do the dad thing cuz You Know Who
I am and you know like I'm about that
life
like don't answer like I'm asking you
for real you owe me nothing this is you
do you believe that there's something
out here that's bigger than you he said
of course I do dad I said do you believe
as a human being not in a braggadocious
way but that you are the greatest level
of all creation he's like you mean like
over a deer
I was like yeah a deer hit me like you
mean better than the ego of my year like
a ego he was like of course because we
could make decision we can do things I
said ok ok I just wanna go back again
you don't believe you were created he
said no but you believe there's a higher
power
he was like yeah and and I said ok ok ok
you believe it's a human you powerful he
was like a forest I say so as a human do
you believe you were just worn to being
a relationship have sex and have money
and buy stuff he was like mmm no I guess
it's something bigger than that dad it's
like I guess the other thing is our
calling I said well if you believe that
why have you never gone after your
calling why you spent so much time
worrying about a relationship why you
spent so much time so worried about
money and cars and stuff if you really
believe what you just told me that as a
human is something greater than that
then weren't you own that he was like I
don't know I said cuz here's the trick
son if you get this in that you still
might not get you I'm just being real
weird to my time I think it's a fun
fabulous place
it's great but I didn't walk in there
like like it was really the the
mountains that made me go whoa it was
really when I saw the birds flying that
I was like unbelievable it wasn't really
the room that I was like this is the
great as a matter of fact the guy was
getting on my nerve I guess when you pay
money to go there they got to try to do
the whole personable thing I'm like I'm
on the thal please just give me the keys
I go to my room and if I have some
problems when I get to my room I will
call you so I'm having a conversation
with my son saying son do me a huge
favor don't go after low-hanging fruit
here's the deal if you get to the top of
the tree all the food from the bottom of
the top is gonna be there son so I don't
need you focusing on cars and money and
stuff you're gonna get dad I need you to
focus on why you were born in the first
place why are you here on earth for this
particular time what are you doing here
anybody can buy a car son animals get in
relationships animals or have sex you
have kid its son it's got to be deeper
than that if you're higher than humans
then while you're here you got to do
more than where animals do and so when
they talked about dreams and legacy I
was like you know people don't get it
write this down
your DNA is in your dream your DNA is in
your dream so so it was funny I was
walking with CJ father the other day and
we were talking and I promise y'all like
every single time we talk I don't care
when it is I don't care how long we talk
we always talk about the relationship he
had with his father and and and I know
that the impact that it had on his kid
as a listen to me
his DNA his dream his DNA is family
like that's all he care about is his son
like when we go out I never saw him
dressed like a certain way like he's
never like hold on II I got to get the
polo shirt in every time I talk to him
it's the same thing his DNA his dream
his DNA his kids has formed his life in
his form who he
man and most of y'all chasing stuff you
don't realize your dreams are so
important because your DNA who you are
as a person is wrapped up in your dreams
and what this world is done to you is
take that from you because they know if
you know who you're drew who you are and
you get your dream you're probably not
gonna work for most of them you're
probably not gonna do most of the dumb
stuff it's like for real if you knew who
you if you knew your dreams and you knew
and you followed your dreams you
followed your delay most of you probably
would've never been on drugs I've never
met a person before who knew who they
were and was on drugs rule number four
grind people say ey you're getting up so
early morning three o'clock because I
was on I was on the beach with my wife
not too long ago we was holding hands
walking up the beach and my wife said I
know it's hard for me to quit my job but
promise me I'll never have to go back to
work again
[Music]
adrián let me tell you some Adrienne
when she said that I was like you'll eat
when you get home you got a grind bro
you might have to start getting up at
2:30 you might might might even go to
sleep right that's it I'm just saying
I'm telling you I never did this before
I start looking at my booking gigs I
realized like I say no to 750 to 1000
gigs a month I start doing my homework
yo I start man I was just with this dude
got the top podcast in the world and I
start doing my homework
I paid a couple of people do some
homework for me I called my man he's
like you'll eat you ain't operating on
10% of yo here's I yo E for real bruh
I've been with the best
don't nobody communicate he's like yo
most dudes right they can only talk to
one group E he like yo you it don't make
a different way age don't didn't make a
difference with ethnic background he
like yo eat you the greatest
communicator on the earth right now you
only operate now about 10% I was like yo
always trying to go to work I'm telling
you I've been thinking I've been making
calls that's what I'm asking you to do
what fuse you the reason why you so lazy
is not because you don't have the
ability you so lazy cuz your dream so
small your dreams are so far rule number
five don't sabotage yourself I'm
thinking about people sitting here right
now
like you're ill you got a car that you
shouldn't have because the car now is a
symbol is it's a symbol of success
instead of just getting a whip that's
gonna get you from A to B and you can't
say 500 or it's like I said people look
at my crib like yo key I can't believe
you later but for me more is what you
said I was always on that if I live
under my means I'm gonna always have
money so the more money I make the more
money I'm gonna make cuz I ain't
spending no more money you thought I'm
saying and so I don't have a TV
I broke we got a 72 inch TV on the wall
that my wife one brush she went shopping
and spending $100 that some little
furniture store a spot and they called
it like you know we got a TV friend she
thought it was playin is like no I got
TV for you but I had that same plasma
that was sweet when I first bought it
ten years ago on the wall but it's to
your point it's like I don't need to
make more money if I stop spinning it
you know I'm saying abouts I don't have
to get a new car every year I don't have
to get a new I don't have a watch I
don't have know anything I missed it's
like I did want to go some gold teeth
Deion Sanders is back in the day the RDI
were pulling it out I just want one with
my kid's name in it my girl name is the
bottom y'all said I was always think I
could get that I want but I remember my
cousin sending me about jewelry he was
just like yo jewelry you could put it
back and you can make money off of what
I was just I okay whatever I'm not
really into that you know I gotta clean
and keep up with it but I'm just saying
to your point I think they need to hear
some of us are sabotaging ourselves
because we're trying to keep up with the
Joneses or we try to have a certain
image and it's like yo you could get a
Ford Fusion to do what you're doing I'm
saying cuz you parking it and you spend
an eight to ten I was just somebody job
anything like you driving that sucker
around on a regular basis so I think for
a lot of us if we would stop trying to
keep up with the Joneses and we would
build our self-esteem up we could save
money and then from that like you said
we could start you know come on I'm just
saying cuz I hear people say all the
time I need to make million I'm like yo
I'm gonna be real with you you don't
need to make millions that live like a
millionaire like I promise you that life
that you're talking about you really
don't need to ball out of control like
that to have a life where you have your
time crazy that you're free done rule
number six
don't confuse goals with dreams here's
the deal you from now on if it's
something personal call it a gold thrill
let's let's let's get the terminology
right if you want a car we're gonna name
matter that's the goal
don't put your car in the same category
as my Luther King when he said I have a
dream don't put down put that in the
same category that's different category
if you're trying to build your business
portfolio that's the goal when you use
the word dream now you were changing
other people's lives when dr. Mohler the
King said I have a dream
he already had a PhD when he said I have
a dream he was already a minister at
Ebenezer Baptist Church when he said I
have a dream he already had a car when
he said I have a dream he already had a
wife when he said I have a dream he
already had children when he said I have
a dream he had already won the Nobel
Prize when he said I have a dream he had
already met with the president when he
said I have a dream he was already one
of the most influential people on the
planet when he said I have a dream he
wasn't talking about himself he was
talking about you and I and so I want
you to read it fine when you say money
you say go so I have a goal I have a
target when you say I have a dream
that's beyond you rule number seven get
yourself to the next level when I was
doing a PhD and one of the professor's
bless her heart she know no better
she probably grew up privileged or
something so she didn't know so she ran
my paper and was like I don't think
you're gonna be able to pass the
dissertation and I knew where she was
coming from like I wouldn't like she no
hate her but what she was doing was
saying as a critical thinker based on
where you are right now
she had a slice idea I was getting
better every day so you thought you're
talking to me about Who I am right now
we didn't even knew the dissertation yet
you're talking to me about something we
gonna do a year and a half from now you
had a slice idea I'm not gonna be the
same version I will not be the same
person in a year and a half that I am
right now well I wouldn't be sitting in
your class
you know I need you to hear what I'm
saying you are too old to be sitting
somebody classroom trying to get a grade
we're a passphrase y'all
that's like elementary school you won't
get a star some that's elementary school
you won't somebody take you out for ice
cream
cuz you did what you're supposed to do
it's a different level when I went out
listen to me when I went to college I
didn't go to college but nobody degree I
realized that grown up in Detroit
Michigan my mom worked for Ford my
father who wasn't my biological father
worked for Jim I knew where I was called
to be and what I was called to do my
parents could only take me so far I went
to the classroom to find the language
that I needed to get to the next level I
wanted to hear what you know hear what
I'm telling you I already knew I was
gonna be successful but I didn't have
some of the language so I was going to
class and look how they put citizens
together I was looking to find out when
you put this word and this word how you
style you're not here what I'm telling
you I wasn't going for nobody grades and
still got good grades but I wasn't going
for grades I was going for the cold
what's the code I need to know the code
what's the code rule number eight become
a shark somebody asked me like Joey
how do you stay fired up brah you've
been doing this since she was 19 it
seemed like there me and dad were there
bad I mean your dad was talking he was
like 'hey i listen to so many other
motivational speakers eat and it just
seemed like you get better and better i
said i get better and better because the
thing that pumped me up in the beginning
is the thing I think about every day I
wake up every day like yo E you gotta
take control brah
because if you don't take control we
live in a society outside of your house
you live in a world full of sharks this
world is run primarily by sharks and I
promise you if you don't become one they
will eat you alive
rule number nine be specific gotta be
specific you gotta say I'm gonna make
three hundred and twenty five thousand
four hundred and eighty two dollars a
year
it's being realistic you got to say now
you gotta say it like you got to get a
wordy exact you can't be like I want to
be rich in the world like I don't know
what that is I don't know what rich is I
don't know what that means
are you hearing me and rule number ten
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is start playing big this is what's
so crazy like even as I stand here like
I can't believe I'm in Columbus Ohio
like I can't believe I'm with Lewis
Howes like I can't believe I went to
some of the greatness like guys I was I
was just homeless like I was just
literally sleeping in abandoned
buildings I was literally just thinking
about committing suicide right and so so
what happened was I was introduced I was
probably about 16 almost 17 and I was
introduced to a pastor a friend of mine
took me to church with him and it was
the oddest thing I went to church maybe
about three or four times and I didn't
grow up in church so I wasn't really
there for like the religious aspect of
it but this was my best friend and this
is where he went regularly right and and
I loved it it kind of reminds me of this
summit you know it was a lot of positive
people right first time of my life
being in an environment with just
positivity right they would sing and the
pastor would speak and we'd have a
dinner after every church service I
think that's probably why I went cuz it
was like a meal really yep said when you
homeless and your high school dropout
you in that trash can like a hot meal is
just unbelievable right that's why I'm a
foodie to this day right and so but I'll
never forget he would say to me you know
maybe maybe three or four weeks into
going regularly you know he said to me
kid
what are you doing with your life I'm
like what does that mean exactly he's
like what what's your goal is what your
dreams like I don't have any goals any
dreams like my biological father wasn't
in my life my mom got pregnant on me at
17 years old like I don't come from what
you know what what we call like the
older mills experience you know I'm not
like you know my great-grandfather a
picture with my grandfather then my
father and me like I don't I don't know
what I want to do and I remember maybe
about the second month of coming to
church he would say to me he say you
know what you need to get your GED and
you need to go to college and I was like
what
like don't you know I'm living like I'm
living in abandoned buildings like I'm
working at McDonald's and I'm eating
McDonald's like got at like my mother is
717 when she had me she didn't finish
height well she barely finished high
school she didn't go to college my
grandma had 14 kids none of them went to
college like we don't do college you
know and it was just so weird this is
why you need to be in this type of
environment because this environment
activates and give you permission to do
I'm sorry I get excited cuz I'm not
supposed to be on this stage listen to
me I was literally homeless I was coming
to church not really taking showers I
wasn't brushing my teeth and this guy's
looked at me and said you need to get
your GED you need to leave Detroit I'm
gonna sing you to college cuz greatness
is upon you guys that's why this
environment is so important because what
he did was he allowed me to see who I
was before I could really see who I was
and he saw guys I just we just buried
him about four weeks ago and and and he
saw something in me like like everybody
in the world now says like you know et I
watched your video and this happened in
AB and et you know I get inspired I was
16 17 years old I had never spoken a day
in my life and this guy saw it like he
saw something to me that I didn't see
and he gave me permission to be where
other people said I couldn't be he gave
me permission to believe I was great he
gave me permission to think I can change
the world he gave me permission to start
something that had never started in my
family before he gave me permission to
say
[Applause]
he gave me permission to say I am
brilliant yeah I might be different but
I am brilliant yep I might be loud but I
am special he gave me permission and so
the first thing I want you to do today
is I want you to keep saying to yourself
I am I am I am I am and for those of you
who hadn't quite started yet I am and
for those of you who gotten started I am
why because I can't believe that I
started with a GED and that GED turned
into a four-year degree took me 12 years
guys it took me 12 years but pastor will
keep telling me you are brilliant you
are special Eric yes you're different
and yes you're not doing it the
traditional route but greatness is upon
you you got to keep going you got to
keep going you got to keep going in the
12 years to get the four-year degree
turn into a master's degree and the
master's degree turn into a PhD guys I
can't believe it I went from being a
high school dropout from being homeless
living in abandoned buildings to eating
out of trash cans to dr. Eric Thomas to
writing six books guys are you hearing
what I'm saying today
stop playing small and start playing big
because
now I've got a bonus clip from et on how
to be in control that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to actually taking action in your
life or your business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one what do you need to start
playing bigger at number two get
specific write down specifically what
you need to get bigger at and number
three what will you do to make sure you
don't sabotage yourself on this bigger
thinking path
more teenagers and young adults die from
suicide than from cancer that self what
that self would good that self-inflicted
so that people who lose ago we got
teenagers out here committing suicide
it's more than this that more teenagers
are died in AIDS birth defect stroke
pneumonia and flu or influenza chronic
lung disease combined you take all this
and you've got more kids killing
themselves then I'm getting diseases and
die we are losing control and it's time
for those of you in this room to take
control I told you right someday you
could be living this some day you've
held up your someday either you didn't
get the right information or you got it
you didn't use it you not getting up
early enough you're not taking it back I
don't know what you're doing but when
you leave all I want for you is to live
your someday
if you want more Eric check at the top
fifty rules video we did on him the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continued to believe and I'll
see you there in life when you roll the
dice
worst case scenario you're gonna land on
average so don't be average because if
you don't try you will get to happen